six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number let's go to
our next caller from the five seven zero
area code caller from five seven zero go
ahead a David exam of the show there's a
lot of spoofing on the didn't ask for
Bitcoin lately and I've been thinking
about getting involved with it but do
you think that the bidding and the the
spoofing can be fixed really without
regulation Oh
tell me more about what you yeah I
missed a word there you said there's
been spoofing did you say we're with
Bitcoin yeah it's on the bid and ask for
Bitcoin that'll happen a lot with a
price manipulation yes all I mean we're
getting very technical here but there is
something you can do if you don't make
market orders for buying and selling and
I know that this immediately a bunch of
people in the audience his eyes are
glazing over if you make sure that you
are putting in limit orders where you
are saying what's the price you're
willing to pay or accept for sell it for
buying or selling Bitcoin you do solve
like 90% of the bid-ask sparc --it
orders are overwhelmingly what's
responsible for that and I don't I don't
necessarily know enough about it to say
we need or don't need regulation but
wouldn't just avoiding market orders
solve a lot of the problem yeah I mean I
would imagine but you know you have
people submitting like this and ask for
like a million dollars you know just a
little bit below or a little bit above
like the price of the actual bid you
know yes all right well listen like I
said I don't know about the the
regulation is a solution but avoid avoid
the market orders and I think that that
that will solve a lot of the problem
thanks for the call very much appreciate
it